Hello, nice to be with you in
cyberspace. I'm Chad Littlefield,
co-author of this book "Ask Powerful Questions:
Create Conversations That Matter." And in this
video, we're gonna answer the question "How do
you start a conversation
in a group virtually or in person?" So,
how do you start a conversation in a
group. Right after the intro plays, I'm actually
going to show you how I started a conversation
in a group of 282 people. I was leading a
workshop titled "The Art of Remote Connection"
with people who are on our newsletter list,
sent down emails saying, "Hey,
free workshop on Friday,"
282 people... beautiful human beings turned up
and so I'm just going to queue up the clip of
what happened right before that workshop and then
officially, as we got started...right after that
plays which is about a minute or so, we're gonna
unpack the learnings from that and then dive
into this little Ask Powerful Questions
pyramid and explore a little amazing
secret that changed the way that I start all
conversations with groups and individuals,
whether you're meeting virtually or in person.
I'm Chad Littlefield, let's get into it.
So, real quick before we queue
up this footage from Zoom,
directly from Zoom, directly from me starting
a conversation, a little bit of context. So,
282 people hopping in, we had the waiting
room enabled on Zoom and the first thing
that I did and the tip that I want you to
pay attention to and just see what happens
is... and to be honest, I was kind of... I've
been experimenting with this more and more
is in person, even in a group of 1000 people,
if I'm speaking, I always look to make a few
small connections. Just have, you know, there's no
way I can connect with everybody at scale before
the presentation, before a workshop, but what I
can do is have a few quality interactions. And a
cool thing that happens is at the end, those few
people that I connected with are always the ones
who are like more enthusiastic to raise their
hand or feel a little bit more comfortable to
take the risk of sharing and contributing
in the group. So, here we go, let's meet
Ginger and Nicole. Hello Ginger, hello
Ginger, hello Nicole. I let you both...
we're gonna let a whole bunch of people
in in a minute but I let you both through
because y'all should connect. So, look at
each other's names, maybe pin each other
and make sure to connect on LinkedIn and that's
all I'm going to say before we get rolling here.
117 people are waiting.... Hi!
All right, lovely. So, I'm not going to fast
forward, the workshop went on for another
90 minutes, I'm not going to cut to the end
but you'll see that when we do a Q&A and ask me
anything in the end, Ginger and Nicole were 2 of
the heaviest contributors in the group.And I think
part of the reason is that they're connectors
but the other part of the reason is that... and
I did this with intention because I felt like and
thought that they were special and I had known...
I had an email exchanges with a couple of them
before but letting them through, before we were
in the session with, you know, 200... hundreds of
people, there was some really magical thing that
happened that throughout the entire workshop, it
felt a little bit more personalized, a little bit
more meaningful just to them. So, now what's about
to happen in the video is I'm about to undo the
waiting room and let everybody flood in. And so
I want you to just watch the first few minutes of
that and see what I did to start a conversation
in groups or to welcome people and create some
sense of connection in community even though we're
in a group of a lot of people. In fact, I want you
to count how many times I used people's names.
Names are like an on switch for our brain, right?
My theory is when we're in a group, the more we
can use names or using names as much as possible,
as organically as possible increases the
sense of connection. It's a really great
way to start a conversation in a group
to acknowledge individuals in that group.
What you want to avoid starting a
conversation in a group is anonymity,
right. What a terrible way to start a conversation
in a group is by saying, "How are you all?"
Right? It's the... in psychology,
there's a thing called the Kitty Genovese
effect. It's kind of a gruesome observation
or study but, the study was essentially...
there was a woman who was walking home... not
leaving, I think she's walking home and she was
outside her door in a L-shaped or U-shaped rather,
apartment complex. So, the doors were right at
my thumbs here and she was walking in, she was
actually stabbed and I was... I think estimated in
apologies to the psychologists in the world
if I get this number slightly wrong but
I think there were 27 people that saw this
happen. They were looking out their windows,
they heard Kitty Genovese's screams, saw
this happen but no one called the police. And
what that is often referred to as the Bystander
effect. It's the, "Oh, someone else will do it so
I'm not going to." So, you're driving down the
street and you see a car accident and it looks
like it's happened a while ago and there's a ton
of traffic, you're like, "Oh, there's somebody
else is gonna... somebody else has already
called. I'm not going to bog down the police."
And that might be true in that specific instance
but also when the Bystander effect shows up,
it's the psychology of
passivity. It's like... it's the psychology
of why we stand back and and don't
speak up and do something. And one way to
decrease that anonymity and create a more cohesive
community and a group is to use people's names.
So, I think that's enough framing. Just count how
many times I use names in this quick little
clip. I'm gonna let everybody flood in so,
I see you, I love you, I'm glad you're
here and I'm gonna let 120 more people in.
All right, hey. Welcome,
welcome. Hi Jack, hi Melissa.
Oh, it's good to see smiling faces. Suzanne,
it's nice to see... Suzanne, is this like our
3rd Zoom like we did the annual conference
at the beginning like... we're going at it,
I love it. Isaac, you're cheering. Did you...
were you kickstarter supporter? Nice. Hi Stacybud,
good to see you. Hi Jen Cassarcy, good to see you.
I totally butchered your name there, Jen Casir.
Now, really important reminder is I'm not just
sharing people's names with no intention. You saw
there was a few times that I had personal contact.
So, I knew, you know, I had... there were clients
on that call, there were people that I'd worked
with in the past, people who I exchanged emails
with, people maybe who have even left comments
on YouTube videos if they liked the video.
And so, I was making personal connections rather
than just saying, right, like the trick is not...
it's not a trick to begin with, but the idea is
not to say, "Hi! blah, blah, blah, blah, blah" and
just rattle off a bunch of names that you
see on Zoom gallery view. That doesn't really
create connection, if anything it might actually
create that separation. So, as much as possible,
as organically as possible; and depending on
your group size, that might only be 3 or 4 names
but it still breaks down that effect of anonymity
and says, "I see you." And that's where I want to
go and unpack the 2nd rung or the 2nd layer of
this Ask Powerful Questions pyramid, I see you.
So, if you can look at this pyramid, this
would be really cool. If you had a magic wand
and your goal was to start a conversation
in a group virtually or in-person,
it would be really convenient if you could
do it in a way that just said all at once,
"I'm willing to know you. I see you, I hear you,
I get you, I'm with you," right? That would be
a convenient, maybe over the top but it would
be convenient to be able to just snap your
fingers and do that. Not possible and so, what
we've developed, what Will and I have created
is this how-to pyramid that unpacks
and helps create this impact. And so,
at this level of I see you, names are one part of
that but a bigger part of that is our own natural
genuine curiosity. When we are naturally
curious about other people, it's obvious.
When we're asking questions out of
obligation or we're not genuinely curious,
it is also obvious. And so, one other really
great way to start a conversation in a group
virtually is to be curious about one very
specific thing in that group. So, you can start
a whole flood of connections if you just say,
"Hey, Joe. I saw that post on LinkedIn that you
did. What's the story behind that?" So, asking
that question and hearing Joe's response...
connections are kind of this exponential
thing that when somebody shares something,
everybody in a group is inclined to see themselves
in whatever's being shared. So, when Joe answers,
it's likely that somebody else
will be, "Oh me too," or "Oh,
no way. What about this?" or "I
didn't know you lived here," right?
There's gonna be all these connections
that jump in and so, the path to start
a conversation in a group might just
be 1 specific curiosity, 1 question.
So, you're inviting contribution from 1
person, you're kind of
facilitating that as opposed to the
anonymous way of "How are you all doing?" If
you've got a really engaged group, they might
answer that but it's really easy for the critics
and consumers to sit back and be really passive
in that conversation. So, if you really want to
invite everybody in and create this culture of
connection, belonging and trust and inclusion,
ironically, one really great pathway to start is
curiosity about just 1 person. When they answer,
everyone else can see themselves and comment how
they see themselves in that response. And you can
help facilitate that along. This entire video was
based off of like a first 1 minute of a 2-hour
workshop of an entire series on the Art of Remote
Connection and several activities, exercises that
we did breaking down that. So, you can check out
the link in the description and these videos right
here are really great follow-ups if you enjoyed
this content, want to dive a little bit deeper,
want to be a better connector in the world.
I'm Chad Littlefield, have an awesome day.